well how about this when the league year
officially begins tomorrow at 4 pm this
trade will go down odell beckham jr from
new york to cleveland in exchange for a
first a third and a nice young safety in
jabril peppers
mike florio has
more the cleveland browns go all in now
that they have odell beckham jr a guy
that makes them feel like a serious
contender what they do remains to be
seen but this kind of made me at first
blush when the rumors already merged
last week think of reggie white to the
packers in 1993. the packers already had
their quarterback they already had other
pieces but it was that one superstar
talent to legitimize the team and
elevate it to a new level that's what it
feels like is happening i'm sure the
browns love the fact that in the same
week that antonio brown will be exiting
the afc north as a member of the
steelers odell beckham jr arrives as a
member of the cleveland browns and the
browns now feel like the team to beat in
the afc north with the addition of odell
beckham jr that's a far cry from how
that organization felt a year ago
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports